ou bien faut pas vrai nom mais pas assez
rigoureux vous êtes déjà filmé bah ouais
avec tout le monde
ah oui mais pas moi mais allez pas moi
s'il fait vite faire un prime avec
plaisir comme ça comme ça n'a quand vous
êtes déjà filmé avec lui avec mon
compagnon a détruit près sur la tête de
ma mère
maman j'espère que son père et regarde
pas imaginons pas ce soir oui je peux
toujours démunis est ce que c'est que
cette histoire de sexe tape il pas déjà
ternie papa dans maman et à filmer non
mais franchement
non mais attendez un supprimés après
quoi vous supprimez pas on regarde on
sait mais les gars quand même et vous
faites 10 10 mais qui filme bannu banon
une équipe de tournée maillot non mais
oui c'est bien la paire quoi c'est vrai
oui mais vous mettez la perche crois
mais c'est vous vous avez fait un maman
[Musique]